come on dude I'm still trying to reach
out to you I'm Ben Schwartz wait I have
something for you can I show the video
from Ben yes oh yes this is an exclusive
in Austin
I think you're a fan I watched Sonic
last night dude I'm hilarious you didn't
tell me the bench warrants was the voice
of Sonic I thought he was hilarious
that's cool I'm totally cool saying
goodbye now
apologize to the guy man I that's
exactly what I have to do I told him I
heard it was a movie so
the experience is wonderful I can't wait
to see it but I wanted to invite you and
we all wanted to fight you it's one of
our improv shows so here we have
quota we have just oh my God
we want to invite you to a benchmarks
and friend show any City you want to
come to you tell us
and James says you could probably stay
at his place
congratulations on everything buddy oh
my God that literally just made my month
as I said weeks ago when you first
entered this courtroom that this was the
last trial of my career
what I didn't tell you is it's also the
first uh because I'm not a real judge
and you're not a real four person
this is not a real case
what
the weekend after like I I was paranoid
I remember going out and I was at
restaurants and I would just make eye
contact with people and it was just
totally random and coincidental they'd
divert their gaze almost instantly and I
remember thinking like oh wow are there
still cameras on me so I was texting
James I was like hey I don't know if
this is normal I was like I'm kind of
freaking out I'm feeling a little
paranoid and in the middle of me texting
him because James is just the wonderful
human that he is he calls me right up we
talk on the phone for 30 45 minutes he
steps he starts helping me walk through
this process you know and that's really
when I started to come to terms with
everything I was feeling and started
working through those feelings this is
three weeks of somebody's life and I was
like this is a this can be a tricky
thing to navigate and what was Paramount
to me that by the end of it he knows
that this wasn't all fake that the
connections he made the friendships that
that were that sprung from this or all
authentic and real
[Music]